And it's funny because when
people see old pictures of me,
they say I either look like the Jersey,
like a jersey shore wannabe or like a
backstreet boys wanted me cause I looked
like, cause I had the earrings in
and I had the hair totally spite.
And yet that was the style at the time
we were also running a risk because
you've got like a little bit of
facial hair. Yeah. Yeah. I don't have,
it's not very masculine. No a beard,
but she's got something going on.
It's definitely a man or you're a woman
undergoing hormone replacement therapy.
You got that Chaz Bono type thing.
It's um,
this is called a lazy man's beard because
I can't even even really grow a beard.
So it's just this is what
it is when I get lazy.
You got a little something going
on though? Yeah, I guess so.
Maybe it's the finasteride just
had the mustache itself though.
It be kind of creepy.
No mustaches.
I'm going on a jihad against mustache
just because I think for whatever reason
they look more ridiculous than
full facial hair. I don't know why.
Some people like, like Sam Elliott, the
actor. I don't know who that is. I know.
I know Tom Selleck, so I've seen
roadhouse. Which guy is it in row?
Sam Elliott. Everybody knows who that's
not the main character. Patrick Swayze.
Oh my. Yeah, but he's got the, he's
got the fucking mustached. What a man.
But the GRANDPA vibe going on that
he didn't always go to roadhouse.
Go to look at that. Sam
Elliott. He's a great voice.
Nobody's blowing him
because he has a mustache.
Easy blow his fucking game area.
Look at that.
Come on. Yeah, I mean with the,
the hair right there. Right there.
That's him and roadhouse. Yeah,
but that's a full beard. That's
more of a full beard. That's true.
And that looks better on them.
I Dunno. Look at that. Oh,
come on now. I don't think a go to
that. I got that one right there.
I don't think a goatee looks as
ridiculous as a mustache alone.
Some guys can pull it off. It's
a bold choice, but it can't look,
you can't look overly Archie with it.
You know what I mean?
You can't or you can't.
No you can't. If you're,
if it looks like you're tied to your
goatee as a matter of your identity,
then it's a problem.
But if it's just a dude who seems like
he's rocking a goatee cause he just
decided one day to rock a goatee,
then it's all right.
You know what kind of died out the
soul patch, the soul patch. Yeah.
I haven't seen one of those in forever.
You know, that kind of went away.
Did you ever have any facial
hair? No beard, just beards.
I grew up way out at one
point in time because a,
there's a guy named Evan Tanner who was
a MMA fighter that was known for having
a big, thick, crazy beard.
He was a really interesting
guy and he really nice guy too.
And he died in,
um,
he went on sort of a walkabout and
decided to go in death valley and camp out
and um,
he ran out of water.
It couldn't find his water and
any wound up dying from heat.
And a lot of us were
pretty broken up about it.
So a bunch of people online decided to
grow out our beards for a certain amount
of months. That's me with a full
beard. Wow. So you get a an almost,
you could get a caveman beard going if
you want it. Oh yeah. I get a full beard.
Yeah. And that's me trimming
around the cheeks because my shit,
my shit creeps all the way up to
my nostrils. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I grew that out for a couple of months.
I forget how long we decided
to go look at, you know,
what are you doing? Listen, that was
when he wanted to play Robert Shapiro.
Didn't he do that for the Oj movie?
I feel like it was okay. Maybe
it's just, yeah, that this,
uh, verifies every single, you
know, whisper about John Travolta,
tickle a ball. Tickets.
That's what it is. Just to,
it's right there for tickle him balls.
Anyway.